[Musique]
José Legault Hélène buzetti allait
castongué bonsoir
bonsoir On va reparler des armes aussi
de cette commémoration aujourd'hui à la
Polytechnique on va vous allez voir
madame monsieur revoir ses belles images
solennelles ce devoir de mémoire mais
d'abord un petit mot sur ce rapport du
VG Alex vous aviez la vérification
générale à votre émission ce midi puis
j'ai goûté
je me disais pas si choqué tu as dit oui
c'est une comptabilité
dans le fond il y avait urgent il y
avait tellement une urgence à l'époque
qu'on comprend pourquoi donc oui il faut
suivre les choses mais il y avait un
mais est-ce que je me trompe
non elle le dit grosso modo si je
déconne les paroles d'une comptable
effectivement on aurait pu faire mieux
mais dans l'urgence de la situation
compte tenu de l'ampleur des programmes
ça aurait pu être payé c'est un peu ça
qui nous dit quand on dit on a envoyé
quatre points 6 milliards de dollars à
des personnes qui n'y avaient pas droit
c'est sûr que le chef le chiffre l'air
énorme mais c'est sur 210 milliards de
dollars c'est 2% en réalité des sommes
qui ont pas été envoyées au bon endroit
contente de faire 10 milliards de
transfert de tout ça ce programme
exactement pour les entreprises pour les
particuliers les sortes de subventions
donc sur 210 il y en a 4.6 qui ont été
mal dépensés 2%, c'est pas c'est pas
idéal mais c'est pas énorme et là il y a
un autre 27 milliards qui est un peu
flou où là on veut récupérer cet argent
là est-ce qu'on va être capable d'y
arriver est-ce qu'on sera pas capable
d'y arriver elle dit il faut mettre plus
de ressources pour que l'agence de
revenus du Canada mettent plus d'efforts
ça on a mal calculé l'effort que ça
prendrait pour récupérer la zone grise
est-ce que ces personnes là il y avait
droit ou non donc elle dit c'était mieux
de le faire de cette manière là que de
pas le faire la plupart des pays ont
procédé de la même manière maintenant
c'est le temps d'essayer de récupérer ce
qu'on peut récupérer donc oui il n'était
pas c'était pas au rapport coup de poing
comme on en a déjà vu de la part de la
vérité générale
de l'eau moulin ou conservateurs qui ont
dit encore aujourd'hui vous avez trop
dépensé et puis en dépassant trop vous
avez pas aidé à calmer l'inflation en
fait sans partir une gare de chiffres je
pense que c'est plus que ça parce que
vous avez mentionné le 27 qui
s'additionne au 4 il y a un peu de flou
même le rapport dit ça pourrait
peut-être être un peu plus que ça donc
si ces chiffres-là s'avère on parle
plutôt de 15% des sommes mais c'est vrai
l'urgence commandait d'agir vite mais là
maintenant on est passé cette urgence et
tout va dépendre de quel assiduité ou
quels mettra le gouvernement pour
récupérer ses sommes et je pense que
politiquement c'est là où il y a
peut-être un danger pour le gouvernement
Trudeau qui a été étiqueté comme étant
trop prodigue trop généreux ayant
contrib comme vous l'avez dit le disent
les conservateurs à l'inflation donc
montreront-ils du zèle pour récupérer
ses os c'est ça
la ministre semblait dire que ça va déjà
plus vite que ce que leur rapport
indique mais quand même il y a des
certaines failles dans les informations
et rappelez-vous que le gouvernement
déjà pendant la pandémie avait effacé
certains
dettes si je peux dire quand il y avait
dit par exemple au travailleur autonomes
qui avaient mal compris les règles de
départ qui pensaient que pour se
qualifier le stress 5000 dollars de
revenus bruts et non pas de net il y a
du bon ben c'est pas grave vous pouvez
garder votre argent ce qui avait quand
même créé une certaine iniquité envers
ceux qui eux avaient bien compris les
règles et vous avez le NPD le chef Chugg
meeting qui aujourd'hui nous disait oui
combattons la fraude mais si les erreurs
ont été commises de bonne foi on devrait
pas enquiquiner les gens alors ce
message politique au risque entre
comporte le risque de renforcer cette
image qui est peut-être le talon
d'Achille des je crois
c'est vous
ben moi je suis vraiment de l'école
c'était une urgence et non seulement
c'était une urgence mais les
gouvernements aussi étaient dans le
brouillard il faut il faut se replacer
au printemps 2020 début de la pandémie
confinement perte d'emploi isolement etc
oui le gouvernement Trudeau a peut-être
lancé un petit peu d'argent par les
fenêtres mais combien de drames humains
aussi il a empêché et que ce soit des
suicides des faillites etc et c'était
pas des c'était pas en tout cas pour ce
qui était des particuliers c'était pas
des sommes mirobolantes il y a personne
qui s'est constitué un trésor de guerre
avec ça mais c'était un minimum pour
garder les gens à flots et moi ce que ça
me disait déjà à l'époque c'est que
c'était ça nous montre la nécessité je
sais que ça se croit pas et de ce dont
Michel Chartran même le grand
syndicaliste par là il y a très très
longtemps et d'autres c'est la nécessité
d'un revenu minimum garanti pour les
particuliers qui fait que évidemment
tout ça se règle lorsque vient le temps
de faire ses impôts et en situation
d'urgence ben ça aurait pu paier un
certain nombre de difficultés mais ceci
étant dit oui c'était c'était absolument
nécessaire c'était une urgence avec
U majuscule et même chose pour les
vaccins la puis là je compense plus
rapidement sur l'épisode vaccin mais
Alex également elle disait oui il y a un
certain nombre là Monsieur du club pas
les mêmes chiffres que nous on a 24
millions de doses vaccinées de 12
gaspillées pardonnez-moi lui dit oui
mais ça là dedans il y a 13 millions des
à stresseneca américain que de toute
façon on voulait plus là alors il déduit
13 millions du 24 millions à lettres
on a fait le nécessaire pour être parmi
les pays qui ont obtenu le plus de
vaccins le plus rapidement ils étaient
disponibles avant un paquet d’autres
pays alors est-ce qu'on en a trop acheté
bien sûr ça coûte un peu trop cher oui
si c'est à refaire les Canadiens
seraient majoritairement d'accord pour
faire exactement le même processus donc
est-ce que ça coûte un peu trop cher un
peu comme la PC u oui politiquement moi
je pense que aucun danger là mais là ce
qui est sain c'est qu'on est au Canada
une vérification générale qui peut se
dire ce genre de choses là quand même
oui absolument je suis d'accord avec
Alex moi il y a quand même un petit
détail sur lequel j'ai accroché dans ce
rapport c'est que elle-même la vérité
Catrice n'a pas été capable d'obtenir le
coup par dose parce que c'est un grand
mystère on sait toujours pas exactement
comment ça nous coûter et elle écrit
quelque part selon les données publiques
disponibles d'évaluation bon ces doses
gaspillées ça coûterait à peu près un
milliard de dollars moi ça ça m'a quand
même frappé que notre la chienne garde
ne soit pas capable d'obtenir ces
informations que l'on essaye d'obtenir
depuis ma foi 2 ans oui on a beaucoup
posé la question José un petit mot là
dessus sur les vaccins puis après on
passe à
oui mais c'est il faut se souvenir aussi
que lorsqu'on a finalement eu des
vaccins souvent comme en 2020 on rêvait
de ça le Canada et le gouvernement
Trudeau était très critiqué au début
parce que les Canada avait pris du
retard dans ces commandes de vaccins et
finalement bon tout ça c'est corrigé
c'est corrigé pour le mieux du mieux du
mieux et tant mieux pour les Canadiens
oui oui on disait moi je me souviens en
fait des panels qu'on disait c'est
honteux il y a des gens
regardez les Français regarder les
Américains les Françaises américains en
produisaient enfin la France pas très
loin ok
Polytechnique Je vous remonte ces images
c'était il y a quelques minutes sur le
sommet du Mont-Royal c'est 14 faisceaux
lumineux qui sont apparus en mémoire au
assassiné ça c'est des images en direct
même donc on les laissera et je le
disais le fait que il pleut un peu ça
rend encore la chose encore plus
impressionnante parce que les petites
gouttelettes de pluie comme les
gouttelettes de l'arbre presque font que
les faisceaux monte vraiment très haut
dans le ciel
là où le débat politique reprend c'est
que c'est invité le débat des armes
depuis les amendements on a parlé hier
au projet C21 au fédéral
Alec ça tombe mal pour Carrey price puis
je vous en montrer les
ces nouveaux textes aujourd'hui
mais le débat il est réel quand même
c'était au courant du drame de
Polytechnique oUI NON à quel moment il
le sustent assez périphérique par
rapport au débat de fond qu'il y a
Ottawa on voulait resserrer le contrôle
des armes à feu on avait procédé avec un
projet de loi conjugés trop imparfait
parce que les manufacturiers allaient
pouvoir le contourner on change le
modèle d'armes on change un détail
dedans et hop pour pouvoir avoir des
capacités de chargeurs beaucoup plus
grand etc on a voulu avoir une
définition donc qui puisse évoluer dans
le temps très englobante et on s'est
retrouvé peut-être à ramasser dans ce
filet là des modèles d'armes à feu que
les chasseurs utilisent pas beaucoup
quelques-uns pas celui que carry Price a
sur sa photo d'autres modèles et donc à
savoir on a peut-être été donc un peu
loin assez pour mes contenter les
chasseurs ce qu'on ne souhaitait pas
faire honnêtement donc je pense qu'on
peut recalibrer le projet de loi on peut
certainement l'ajuster pour éviter de
jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain garder
cette législation là je pense est
nécessaire mais en même temps on n'est
pas non plus obligé d'aller
picasser les chasseurs pour rien alors
que dans le fond c'est pas du tout ça
qu'on disait donc je pense qu'on est
capable d'ajuster ça s'il y a de la
bonne volonté d'après ce que je
comprends puis là de Me corrigera parce
qu'elle est plus près de ça à ta voix
que moi je pense que les discussions
entre les parties pour essayer de
corriger tout ça ouais c'est ce qu'on a
l'impression que québécois aujourd'hui
on essaie de de dire effectivement on
veut pas on veut pas picocher pour
reprendre le mot d'Alex les chasseurs
pour rien et puis en fait on n'a pas le
choix on oublie un peu mais le
gouvernement libéral est minoritaire il
a besoin d'un partenaire le NPD n'est
pas d'accord avec ce qui se passe on le
comprend le NPD était cartelé entre ses
représentants urbains et ses
représentants ruraux le Bloc québécois
non plus n'est pas tout à fait à l'aise
alors le gouvernement n'a pas le choix
de revoir ses plans
je pense qu'au départ c'est qu'il y a un
vice de procédure le gouvernement était
très maladroit dans sa façon de procéder
cette idée d'instaurer une définition
qui comme ça peut évoluer dans le temps
selon les nouveaux modèles est une très
bonne idée mais pourquoi ne pas l'avoir
insérer dès le départ dans le projet de
loi qui aurait permis lors des
consultations en comité parlementaire
d'entendre tous les experts qui seraient
venus nous dire si la définition elle
est bonne ou pas si elle risque de
déboucher sur des débordements justement
d'englober des armes de chasse or on
nous amène ça à la toute fin du
processus quand les audiences d'experts
sont terminées et là j'écoutais ce soir
une séance de comité et c'est écouter
plus j’écoutais moins je comprenais
c'est extrêmement technique et je trouve
et ça moi hier c'est je reconnais que
pendant quelques secondes je ne
comprenais pas ce que mes invités me
disaient enfin fallait que je rattrape
dans ma tête ok le 6 5 c'est très dingue
très très technique c'est des précisions
de calibre etc et donc je pense que ce
que le gouvernement devrait faire c'est
reprendre le processus parlementaire
pour pouvoir aborder cette question et
voir qu'est-ce qui en a exactement bon
on rappelle que si on fait le lien parce
qu'on est le 6 décembre mais si on fait
rien c'est que ce débat là au Canada a
pris après la tuerie de Polytechnique
c'est ça qui a été le point de départ de
ce débat depuis 33 ans
trois décennies et ça a commencé dès
1990 donc dès l'année que suivie la
tuerie et j'entendais Nathalie Provost
qui est une des survivantes et très très
présente et qui se bat pour ça aussi
avec d'autres depuis 33 ans
dire nous touchons au but après tout ce
temps-là nous touchons au but donc oui
c'est un parfait oui comme le disait
Hélène et Alec je pense qu'un processus
peut-être à peaufiner ou à reprendre
mais
n'oublions pas l'essentiel et
l'essentiel premièrement ce sont ces 14
femmes là et c'est que comme le dit
Nathalie probault on touche au but pour
ce qui est d'un contrôle des armes à feu
un peu plus serrées et aussi
servons-nous de cette journée-là et de
celle qui vont suivre pour aussi
réfléchir et échanger sur toute la
question des violences contre les femmes
toutes les violences comptées voilà bien
dit un petit clin d'oeil avant de se
quitter sur le site dans votre journal
José vendredi ça fait jaser toute la fin
de semaine encore aujourd'hui hier le
taux's gate est-ce que j'ai le temps de
présenter monsieur Dubé monsieur duwin
il est juste l'extrait de Monsieur Dubé
parce que là lui il s'est lui-même en
perdait son latin est-ce qu'on a
vraiment donné des jours de suspension à
une préposée parce qu'elle a mangé une
toast qui était destinée
aux patients on écoute
c'est pour ça que je dis que tout le
monde là je parle pas juste les PDG là
intermédiaires
qui comprennent qu'on doit être
respectueux de nos employés et qu'on
s'assure qu'on a besoin de tout le monde
est-ce qu'on peut pas mettre sur le bain
de punition des gens pour des niaiseries
alors qu'on manque à ce point de
personnel c'est ça que le ministre a dit
là
un règlement de manière tellement
stricte c'est-à-dire qu'on dit que le
beurre de pinotte et le pain appartenait
au CHSLD et donc aux résidents donc
c'est un vol et un vol c'est punissable
première infraction d'au moins trois
jours de suspension alors bon on a déjà
vu des vols plus importants que prendre
une pause parce qu'on n'avait pas eu le
temps de déjeuner un rappel à l'ordre
amical avec une table sur l'épaule
aurait probablement été suffisante mais
visiblement on n'a pas demandé à ces
cadres-là d'avoir du jugement on leur a
demandé d'appliquer le règlement mais
c'est un bon rappel et si on va
améliorer les conditions de travail dans
le milieu de la santé que d'avoir une
gestion un peu plus humaine près du
terrain plutôt que de se fier seulement
uniquement dérèglement pas de mauvaise
idée quand même José d'avoir le gros bon
sang pas trop loin non plus s'il vous
plaît
oui mais moi je soupçonne fortement que
le ministre du Big était pas si surpris
que ça et c'est parce que c'est un
symptôme parmi tant d'autres des
dysfonctionnements importants dans cette
énorme machine là qui non seulement le
ministère mais tous les cieux c'est les
6 etc et tous les gestionnaires qui
combinent
une espèce de rigorisme bureaucratique
la technocratique sclérosée a souvent
aussi de l'arbitraire des décisions
arbitraires alors c'est ça qui crée des
dysfonctions et je pense pas que c'est
demain matin que ça va se régler
malheureusement
et ces gestionnaires la peur de faire
une erreur aussi comme on a peur de
faire une erreur on en fait trop de part
de se faire dire tu en as pas fait assez
et ça on perd de vue l'initiative puis
le gros bon sang là c'est c'est
compliqué à enlever ça
on fait appliquer les règlements c'est
je pense que c'est le propre de toutes
ces grosses organisations et comme je
vous ai dit le système de santé c'est la
grosse organisation
ultime c'est le propre de ces grosses
organisations de déboucher sur ce genre
d'aberration parce qu'on perd le contact
d'une réalité terrain d'une réalité
concrète et de s’encer dans la réalité
et de faire preuve justement de de
jugement quand le jugement justement ça
commande de parfois interpréter le
règlement et de fou parfois de moi il
s'applique pas vraiment dans cette
circonstance là je vais le mettre de
côté quand c'est trop gros on y va de
bouc passez-moi l'expression et ça donne
ce genre de résultat bon alors on
rappelle aux gens que ça s'est réglé il
y a une intervention de Sonia Bélanger
la ministre monsieur Dubé c'est réglé
mais combien d'autres cas comme ça parce
que c'est aller dans les médias c'est
toujours comme ça ouais parce que c'est
le problème
l'histoire d'une infirmière qui parlait
pas assez anglais je pense que ça
rebondit à la peur des questions par le
passé anglais qu'on n'a pas engagé au 81
alors que nous pour qu'ils viennent
travailler bon c'est comme ça si la vie
merci beaucoup à vous c'est la maison
qui rend fou Patrice bientôt les 40 ans
de ciné cadeau d'ailleurs parlant
merci à la fois aujourd'hui au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI